زعم تحقق تنبؤاته في كثير من الاحيان
كصعود ادولف هتلر واغتيال جون كندي المنجم
الفرنسي الشهير الذي عاش قبل نحو 500 عام
تعود تنبؤاته من جديد عبر تطبيقات الذكاء
الاصطناعي صحيفه ديلي ستار البريطانيه
اللاجئت الى روبوت لاجراء دردشه حصريه مع
توقعات غريبه واخرى مرعبه سردتها النسخه
الرقميه لهذا الرجل للمئه عام القادمه
فوفقا لتوقعاتها في عام 2021 لن يكون هناك
مرض السرطان مره اخرى وفي عام 2050
سيتقاتل البشر في معركه ضد تغير المناخ
اما في عام 2074 فستذهب فرقه من البشر
للعيش على سطح المريخ لكن جائحه جديده
لمرض مجهول ستضرب البشريه عام 2085 الى ان
ياتي العام 20199 يوم السلام والصدق على
كوكبنا بحسب توقعات النسخه الرقميه من
نسترداموس ما رايكم
[موسيقى]